وانهي
وصفويت عندما اصبح عمره خمس سنوات قمنا
بزياره طبيبه نفسيه قالت لي ان ابننا لن
يكون قادرا على الكلام ولن يصبح طفلا
عاديا تخيلي هذا ما قالته لي عن ابني ولكن
ابني يتحدث الان لا يمكن لطبيبه ان تقول
ذلك لاي ام لانها ستسرق منها الامل
[موسيقى]
يجب ان تعطى الامهات بعض الامل كان يجب
عليها كطبيبه ان تنصحني بقراءه كتاب او
فعل هذا الامر او ذاك كان يجب عليها ان
تكون ايجابيه
[موسيقى]
لم اقم بتربيه الحيوانات في البيت يوما
ولكن عندما علمت ان اطفال التوحد يتفاعلون
مع الكلاب دفعته الى اللعب معها في
الحديقه العامه واحب ذلك فعلا واليوم اصبح
لدينا قطط في البيت ويحب اللعب معها كما
يشاء حاولت ان العب كره القدم مع اه لكنه
رفض فركزت على الاشياء التي يهتم بها هو
الان هذا ما يضيف الى تفاعله كاي شخص اخر